you may have noticed during the pandemic
more phishing scams in your emails and
your text messages
law enforcement say con artists are
trying even harder now
to prey on all of us as we're coping
with the coronavirus
nancy chen tells us about a new scam
targeting people already down on their
luck
[Applause]
the pandemic led to job losses and
people signing up for unemployment
benefits online
something con artists have keyed in on
how successful have these scammers been
these scammers have been very successful
unemployment fraud like this is
happening all across the country
in every state steve reagan is with
akamai technologies and recently
uncovered a fake new york unemployment
website
that looks like the real thing it's
since been taken down but reagan created
this one to show us how it worked
scam artists send a text or email
directing jobless workers to their
website
after a username and password are
entered the fake site asks for their
mother's maiden name and pin number
once the information is entered users
are actually sent to the real new york
page
do people who enter in their personal
information on these fake sites even
realize
that they've been scammed no they do not
by the time the scam is over in fact it
forwards you to the real domain
and you'll never notice but the scam
artist now has the info
and can log on as the unsuspecting
victim and find
even more personal information
everything that a criminal would need to
commit fraud using your identity
last year the fbi received almost a
quarter of a million complaints about
phishing scams
with people losing around 54 million
dollars
if you do fall for one of these phishing
scams the consequences can be
pretty severe cbs tech reporter dan
patterson
says criminals who get personal info can
sell it on the dark web
think twice before you click on any link
in your email or your text messages
one way to spot a fake site is to double
check the url
for example this looks like a legitimate
google site
but it's not because of the dot tk at
the end
a small difference that can lead to big
problems if your info
ends up in the wrong hands nancy chen
cbs
news new york